would you say protagonists and comedies
are kind of pathetic not necessarily um
howled Raymond's had this idea that
when he started writing directing uh all
the all the comic protagonists were kind
of nebbishing and pathetic like like in
a Woody Allen film but he but his take
was what he was interested in were the
Rebels the iconoclasts the people who
don't fit in and that's why
meatballs Ghostbusters
um uh their you know uh Groundhog Day
you know Stripes he has he has these
characters that are they're still not
perfect they're still not Heroes because
they lack decorum they lack you know
kind of maturity but they they're
they're Rebels that's because that's how
he saw himself
and so so your comic protagonist doesn't
need to fit the uh cookie cutter form of
some other character that you're not
interested in right about the characters
that you're interested in only remember
they're human meaning they're fallible
meaning you can't accrue to them
all the wonderful qualities you wish you
had
you have to give them the qualities that
they have
and you know and and you have to lead
them on a journey somewhere
So when you say iconoclasts so they're
they're kind of Misfits they don't yeah
Misfits Rebels that's who you like to
write about so so I think it's a mistake
to think that every every uh uh
protagonist has to be a nebish or or a
dweeb they can be uh you know kind of a
a jerk or or somebody who's self-serving
or just doesn't fit into the group for
whatever it does or doesn't fit into the
group for some reason our characters and
comedies different than other genres
they're funnier no
um
again uh
a character in comedy is is the term
that we use in the hidden tools of
Comedy is non-hero a non-hero is
somebody who lacks some if not all the
essential skills and tools with which to
win
so that describes all of us we all
lack some if not all the essential
skills and tools with which to win were
not omnipotent we're not immortal
uh we're not omniscient
um some of us have bad you know uh you
know bad Court eye hand eye coordination
uh so so we
we are flawed and so in in a comic
protagonist uh your protagonist is
flawed only to the extent that they need
to be flooded in other words you don't
need to make him the stupidest person in
the world
because listen as we like to say you're
not as smart as you'd like to think you
are you're you're you know you're you're
just you're just human so so you don't
need to by by making somebody a clown uh
that's that's another mask
you see you put a mask on a character
and on a heroic character and you give
them the attributes Brave resourceful
this and that uh by making somebody an
idiot uh the stupidest person in the
world
um you're still putting a mask on them
and you're and but now you're
condescending to them and you're saying
what you're basically saying is that
that person what a jerk what an idiot
um not me though I'm I'm the smart
writer I'm I'm so is much smarter than
the characters I'm writing and I would I
would
suggest well you know have a little
sympathy
because you know that character even if
it's an anthropomorphic chicken that
character's a human being and so are you
so you know you're all going to end up
in the same place so maybe you shouldn't
spend your time condescending
maybe you should spend your time
connecting
and and you know observing
you know not not letting somebody off
easy not whitewashing something but the
genius of Comedy is that it loves
Humanity without forgiving them
and in Revenge of the Nerds it was it
was set up that we all sort of looked
down on these various characters until
they had their comeuppance except that
in Revenge of the Nerds even though we
kind of knew
that they were they were losers
on the other hand
so are we
I mean how many of us empathize and
related to the good-looking
blonde-haired blue-eyed Perfect Teeth
Frat Boys
no we we in our heads we're all losers
in our heads we're all Misfits in our
heads we're all
um less than
and the genius of Comedy
is that it knows that
and it says it's okay
your secret's safe with me
I'll be the jerk I'll be the loser for
all of you
because the reality is is that that's
what frightens us more than more than
more than death you know it's the most
frightening thing to people public
speaking because in public speaking
you're exposed
am I smart enough do I look good enough
and that's what we all fear that we're
going to be exposed
and a comedian is the person who simply
has the courage to get up in front of a
large group of strangers and admits to
Being Human
whereas many of us
you know we don't admit it you know
we're we're perfect
well at least we want you to think that
we're perfect
how many of us go to our boss and say
boy am I a screw-up today I got this all
wrong no if we screw up we try
desperately to hide it